welcome to eats he lives official
Grammys after-show we are recapping
breaking down the biggest moments of
music's biggest night and boy were there
plenty he's gonna see was it emotional
night to say the least with many
honoring Kobe Bryant the former Los
Angeles Laker died in a helicopter crash
on Sunday morning and the Grammys
actually quickly put together a tribute
and a tribute to a legend in Los Angeles
someone who called the Staples Center
where the Grammys are held home for his
20 year career and in fact the tribute
kicked things off with Alicia Keys the
host with this very very special message
take a look we're all feeling crazy
sadness right now because earlier today
Los Angeles America and the whole wide
world lost a hero and we're literally
standing here heartbroken in the house
that Kobe Bryant built you know news of
Kobe's passing broke at during the red
carpet and it was something that people
talked about there and obviously of
course held close to their hearts during
the entire celebration what you just saw
right there was from Alicia at the
beginning in the show at the end of the
show she closed with another remark for
Kobe blessing his family and then also
her performance with boys two men
whether they performed it so hard to say
goodbye to yesterday an acapella version
of their song you know to honor like you
said you know a legend who called that
same very venue home and went and
obviously this tribute this was a
last-minute decision because again the
news broke Sunday morning the day of the
Grammy Awards but also Alicia did say
the Grammys team never thought that they
would be starting the show in this way
which is eerily similar to when Whitney
Houston died because she died a couple
of days before the Grammys and they also
scrambled to do a tribute but as you
mentioned I mean the news and Kobe his
legacy was weighing on everybody's
hearts and minds and in fact he was he
was honored in many different ways
throughout the Grammy Awards his jersey
number 24 the LA Lakers Jersey popped up
in many
places including in the rafters lit up
there at Staples Center you see both of
his jerseys there and then also during
the show during performances lil nas ex
had a couch set up in one of his shots
of his of his performance and there was
a jersey laying there right on the couch
and then also I know people on the red
carpet in their fashion Priyanka Chopra
for example had 24 painted on her finger
it was something that people wanted to
make sure that they were carrying his
legacy with them throughout the night
obviously on everybody's mind and in
everybody's heart and not just the
celebrities and the amazing artists
inside the Staples Center but also
outside fans flocked to Staples Center
in downtown Los Angeles to pay their
respects to the Laker legend very
powerful as I was leaving to head back
here just floods of fans wearing his
jersey we're heading in the opposite
direction of me to the Staples Center
and this is such such a powerful image
right here all of these images paying
paying tribute to to Kobe obviously an
athlete who meant a lot to a lot of
different people including liz' who
actually opened the entire and I opened
the Grammys with her performance of
because I love you and truth hurts she
actually kicked things off saying
tonight is for Kobe and then she busted
out the opening lines because I love you
which I thought was so perfect and also
perfect because Liz o obviously was the
most nominated artist of the year at the
Grammy Award so it was kind of amazing
that she got to have that moment and she
took that moment to also pay our
respects to Kobe 100% and of course you
and I stand here right now doing this
show and we have nothing but love and
respect to Kobe and his entire family
and I feel like we share the same
sentiments that the Internet does right
now and those who loved him and it's a
devastating loss for everybody you see
the emotional Izzo's face but also it
was a big night for her to begin with
right again leading the pack with eight
nominations Liz OH took home three
Awards tonight she was nominated of
course for the biggies but that actually
went to another lovely Best New Artist
Billy Eilish it was a huge night for
Billy and in fact she swept the general
field categories
here's her speech for the last one of
the night record of the year blink you
might miss
[Applause]
thank you you know Teddy after you win
all the awards that you have won during
the night and you thanked everybody that
you could at the end of the day yeah two
words live will suffice thank you think
about it she was on the stage many time
tonight they were backstage Billie and
Phineas her brother were backstage from
an award they had just won when they got
the last award and they had to run back
up there for it you can't predict that
you're gonna win all of them nominee of
four so I'm sure she think everybody
that she needed to when she took song of
the year followed by Best New Artist
followed by album of the year and then
so by the time they announced record
going through that list but you know
obviously Billie made history even
before she won as the youngest nominee
to be nominated for those four big
general filled categories and you know
what she didn't just stop making history
there she actually made history with her
wins I believe she is the only the
second artist to sweep in the same year
those four big categories the last time
was Christopher Cross in 1981 look at
you go girl it has been a minute she
doesn't know who Christopher Pike is
which even Blanco she's 80 Christopher
Cross so it's definitely before her time
don't think she was born yet but I gotta
tell you the irony is that when each he
caught up with Billie Eilish on the red
carpet before the actual award started
she think she's gonna win a damn thing
take a look it's your first Grammy stand
you have six nominations is that insane
to you you haven't even thought about
this speech what do you mean you're
gonna win girl I'm not but thank you
have you considered what you will say I
don't think I'm gonna I'm gonna say
Billie just didn't want jinx herself
because I will say she took home five of
her six Grammys I just hope after all of
this dead that she still will like talk
to everybody do interviews she won't
pull a like I'm gonna sneak in the side
door anymore but she she doesn't seem
like that type of person she was so
humbled and gracious to be there and I
don't think that's gonna change not only
was she a big winner of the night she
also had one of the most talked-about
performances of the night in case you
guys missed it here's a little clip from
her Grammy performance tonight
oh my god is her voice alone I love it
you know what it's so funny cuz I always
wonder like how she keeps her voice like
for the award show performances
maybe it's the lollipops that she's
always sucking at a word judgment I saw
her at the AMA sucking on a lollipop and
now at the Grammys she was - who told
you - that's her secret she brought some
lollipops to enjoy the evening yeah
I don't blame her you know it's a long
award show I love that another
performance that everybody is talking
about and it was a such an emotional one
Demi Lovato it was her big comeback a
huge emotional moment as she hit the
stage for her first public performance
since her overdose in 2018 this was a
moment you and I were standing by the TV
watching this and obviously she went to
start singing the song and she was so
overcome with emotion you can see right
there a tear falling down from her cheek
she she was so choked up that she could
not sing that they actually started the
set over and then all of a sudden it was
like from start to finish it was one of
the most beautiful ballads I have ever
heard in my entire life and you know
what I'm gonna stop talking I want you
two guys to listen to how powerful this
is
[Music]
talk about comeback just in that
performance alone you mentioned she had
to start the song over and all of a
sudden she just belt it out this is her
new song anyone which actually became
available to stream and download right
before the performance and let me tell
you I could not have downloaded faster
because this is an amazing song
especially because if you really listen
to the lyrics and obviously her story
has become very public ever since you
know her overdose in 2018 she's she in
these lyrics she's crying out for
someone anyone just to hear her on that
stage sing that and just know how far
she has come I mean I there was not a
dry eye in the house when I saw people
give her standing oh and I know you and
I had the chills and I'm and the
Internet did to you and the Internet
also was talking about that ring on her
finger that's - yeah that's by the way I
think is just Julie they don't miss a
thing I think it was just costumes it
was probably a nice little diamond like
I've mentioned the Grammys it was a
heavy night but thankfully we had a
little bit of a reprieve and Alicia Keys
even sat at the top of the show music is
to unite us to bring joy and that's
exactly what little nas ex did in his
amazing amazing Grammys performance with
some special guests for the old town
road remixes I mean you had Billy Ray
Cyrus BTS Diplo Mason Ramsey but this
moment right here you guys bo G big NAS
join little NAS X at the end of that
performance I was hooting and hollering
this was a moment this was a moment
where people were literally like did
that just happen to bring out the
original nas because we knew BTS was
gonna be there I knew Billy of course
was gonna be there even ramsey we knew
all of that and then the way his his
really awesome set up on the stage
worked it was like this revolving lazy
susan guest to join him and that all of
a sudden nas comes out and I think
people honestly had to blink for a
second because they're like holy cow he
gave us like six different performances
and one you guys it was pretty amazing
to watch we tease Kevin Frazier actually
caught up with little nas ex backstage
just after the performance tick like
yeah it was a great performance though
thank you yeah I felt the energy some
things and go as planned but we kept
moving on yeah
I felt like there was a very kind and
sweet spirit in the house tonight and
again tip of the hat to mr. Kobe Bryant
and what he's man I don't know if you
noticed I even put a little special Kobe
on my guitar yeah I did that with my
just happen to have a silver sharpie in
there
you